attention all passengers  Wilford industries wishes you good  morning the temperature outside is minus  119 point six degrees Celsius mr.  Wilford runs our train based on three  principles work honor and order people  love trains  shut this down here to fend for  ourselves never forget who you are Terry  our fortunes built this train and mr.  Wilford is losing control thank you  pushing and it's time we pushed back  there's an idea travelling up train it  wants to set the train ablaze and all it  needs is a spark  older will be restored sometimes you  have to take to find it together  snowpiercer is our don't you pass  through that door  there's no turning back  you  you